most non-state media outlets in russia
have been banned but not sargrad tv
which blends just the kind of patriotic
conservative orthodox values which
underpin putin's regime the pope has
criticized what is happening in ukraine
its wealthy founder constantine
malafayef has been under u.s and eu
sanctions since 2014 for supposedly
funding the separatists in
i can easily survive with western
sanctions unashamedly imperialist he's
also called russia's offensive in
ukraine a holy war and he promotes all
the main talking points of the kremlin's
propaganda so where does this end this
special military operation you said it
would be a matter of days
you would stop to support nazis
when you in britain would
stop to support nazi regime and kiev
obviously the uk and i'm not
the british government but the uk would
say we do not support
uh nazis in ukraine it is like the tiny
number of them
and also the kiev regime is not a nazi
regime so no it's not obviously it's
obviously only for you and for a western
propaganda so russia will keep fighting
in ukraine until the flow of weapons
stops
this is part of our territory we are
divided people and we were divided in
1991
as germans were divided after the war uh
when we
were defeated in cold war we were
divided for russian federation and
ukraine but we are one people
we have one history we have one blood
we are the family
the channel is watched mostly by the
orthodox faithful but it's useful for
the kremlin a new branch just opened in
cursed ukraine after russian forces
occupied the city and took over its
airwaves
zagrad tv is a good illustration of the
christian nationalism that vladimir
putin has made a central part of his
rule this notion of a russian world
where belarus and ukraine aren't
sovereign entities at all a political
idea which the russian orthodox church
and its patriarch kirill have pushed
with religious further
[Music]
the patriarch's support for the war
effort has resulted in calls for the
russian orthodox church to be expelled
from the world council of churches and
despite the threat of prosecution even
some priests within russia are speaking
out
outside the kremlin there's a giant
statue to saint vladimir the 10th
century leader who united the peoples of
ukraine belarus and russia under the
rule of kievan rus and converted them to
christianity in kiev
it seems pretty obvious why putin built
it here but his imperialist dreams so
far have resulted in the biggest split
in the orthodox church in a thousand
years
and the prayers of the faithful for
peace this easter hostage to brutal
politics dana magney sky news moscow